Das Podcast UFO fliegt, ist in Stefan und Florentin, immer witzig, manchmal auch nicht, doch stets bemüht. Stefan Tietze ist ein cooler Typ, na logo. Florian Mill ist in Stefan Tietze verliebt, ist doch eher ein Sache. Manchmal sind lustige Leute zu Besuchen, nur dieser 300-Dollar-Typ fand ich cool.
UFO-Podcast ist der coolste Podcast, auf die Schnelle immer helle.
Opfer hören den Podcast von Rockstar, wie du das was Blinkbrink.
Ob Fehlkunstdates oder Mandela-Effekt, die beiden reden einfach von der Leber weg.
Das Podcast UFO fliegt, Podcast UFO fliegt, Podcast UFO fliegt, Podcast UFO landet, Podcast UFO landet, der Podcast mit Stefan, Florentin und Fredi der Maus. Piep piep, viel Spaß mit der Folge. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast Uro, dpu mit Florian Will und Stefan Thies, wie ihr jetzt ein paar Mal gehört habt. Also falls ihr unseren Namen nicht merken konntet. Ich persönlich möchte mich von diesem Intro distanzieren. Ich habe nichts damit zu tun, es wurde nicht abgenommen redaktionell vor der Ausstrahlung. Ich möchte mich Abstand nehmen. Es finde ich auch immer so affig wie von den Fernsehsendern, wenn dann die Wahlwerbespots kommen von den einzelnen Parteien. Ja. Wie davor immer so ein, äh, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Ja. Was jetzt kommt, oh, oh, oh. Brauchen wir Ausländer in unserem Land? Wir haben damit gar nichts zu tun. Wir haben uns das angeschaut und wir haben es, ich sage mal so, wir zeigen es jetzt mal, aber alle Fans distanzieren sich nicht mehr so davon, wo man auch sagt, ja, ist schon klar, ist ja eine Werbung.
Vor allem jede Form von Distanzierung erhöht ja nur noch das Interesse an dem, was dann kommt.
Wenn ich dir sage, okay, was ich dir als nächstes sage, davon möchte ich mich vollständig distanzieren.
Ja, warum sagst du es dann?
Ich möchte mich davon distanzieren. Ich stehe davon so gute eineinhalb Meter entfernt. Ja.
Ich bin im Raum, aber ich bin nicht... distanzieren. Warum sagtest du dann? Ich möchte mich davon distanzieren. Ich stehe davon so gute eineinhalb Meter
entfernt. Ich bin im Raum,
aber ich bin nicht
nah. Also ich bin
distanziert. Aber was ich auch
finde, ist, dass
sobald sie sich von den Wahlwerbespots
distanzieren,
haben sie sich ja automatisch dagegen
entschieden, von
Funny Frisch, Chips Frisch sich zu distanzieren. Das stimmt, ja. Oder von Burger King oder von Heckler & Koch. Ja. So, da haben die ja sich dann, also ein Distanzieren für drei Prozent der Spots, die dann kommen, ist ja gleichzeitig ein, aber die hinter den anderen stehen wird zu einhundert Prozent. Auch schwierig. Ja, stimmt, das ist schwierig, aber es ist eigentlich nie falsch, sich von was zu distanzieren. Hat sich jemand schon mal davon distanziert, dass er sich von etwas distanziert hat? Ich glaube, es ist schon mal voll. Also wieder rückrudern, dann wird wieder rangerudert, wenn man sich erstmal distanziert. Rangerudert, es wird weggerudert, es wird rübergerudert, es wird gerudert, gerudert, gerudert. Wenn man ins Schwimmen kommt, erstmal zurückrudern und sich lieber erstmal distanzieren. Es ist alles noch so ein Titanic-Ding drin. Wir sind alle noch nicht vom Bild, von der Metapher hier noch nicht von Titanic weg. Ich glaube, da sitzt noch tief. Wir sind noch ganz tief da drin. Menschheit wurde gekränkt. Stell dir vor, die Mondlandung wäre abgestürzt. Aber im Kontext der Zeit ist die Titanic ein komplett lächerliches Unglückchen. Na ja, aber das ist ja die Hybris des Menschen, wir könnten den Ozean bezwingen. Nein, könnt ihr halt nicht! So. Und dann ist es schon... Da haben sich schon ein paar Leute auf die Krawatte getreten gefühlt. Zu sagen... Auf den Schlips, auf die Krawatte, auf den Eisberg getreten. Ja, ich dachte, dass wir das können, können wir nicht. Stell dir vor, die Mondlandung hätte nicht geklappt. Stell dir vor, die wäre abgestürzt und auf unserer Tour gelandet oder so. Und dann so, oh scheiße. Weißt du doch vor ein paar Mal oder danach? Apollo 13 ist abgestürzt, Apollo 11 ist gelandet, richtig? Ja, Challenger-Tragödie, ganz, ganz schlimm. Auch das war ein Tritt ins Gesicht der Menschheit. Aber auch, ja, ja klar, ein Tritt ins Gesicht der Menschheit. Von wem ist dann immer die Frage, weil wir sind ja alle Teil. Von unserem alten Erzfeind Schwerkraft. Warum ist die Titanic gesunken? Fucking Schwerkraft. Fucking Newton. Fucking Jimmy, Jimmy Neutron. Hätte er nicht bei drei anfangen können. Wieso fucking Jimmy Neutron? Die hätte er alles gewusst. Das ist ein Tritt ins Gesicht der Animationskunst gewesen, dieser Jimmy Neutron. Das war nix, das war wirklich nix.
Mir gefällt es sich zu distanzieren, aber wenn ich, wenn mir die letzten Tage, es ist immer, also du hast schon recht, gerade mit der Frage, hat man sich schon mal dafür distanziert, sich von etwas distanziert zu haben? Ich glaube ja. Und die letzten Tage führen mich zu dieser Antwort, weil es ist, wenn ich eins sagen kann nach den letzten Tagen, dann, dass alles passiert, was man kurz glaubt, was man passieren könnte. Weil die ganze Zeit sitzt man da jetzt alleine rum zu Hause so und dann fährt man ab und zu mal irgendwo hin und dann sind die Strassen ganz leer und man denkt sich nur so, man könnte jetzt richtig gut hier einfach so einem Legend-mämäßig rasen. Einfach wie rasen, im Auto oder zu Fuß? Einfach im Auto, schön im Auto lang, einfach wum, weil alles leer, die Ampeln, checken die eigentlich, weil die gehen automatisch in dieses gelbe Blinklicht manchmal und man denkt, geil, kann ich ja aus Filmen, einfach mal rasen. Gerade eben auf dem Weg hierher, im Radio gehört, dass es jetzt gerade ein ganz großes Problem wird, dass alle rasen. Echt? Und so. Ja, die ganze Zeit, und dann denke ich mir die ganze Zeit, hm, wahrscheinlich, jetzt werden alle aufeinander hocken, ist glaube ich nicht so gut oder sehr gut, also entweder häusliche Gewalt, oder es werden ganz viele Kinder gezeugt, eins von beiden, im Radio hört man beides. Man hat schon Namen für die Kinder, die gezeugt werden, Coronials, die in neun Monaten kommen, finde ich super. Und häusliche Gewalt nimmt extrem zu, befürchten viele Leute. Also alles, was man denkt, passiert. Ja, ich versuche ja immer so einen anderen Blick auf die Sachen zu haben, dadurch, dass ich durch meine Vergangenheit viele massiv rechtsradikale Vergangenheit, von der ich mich distanziere übrigens. Sorry. Aber da auch noch mal eine Frage, was muss man leisten, bis es als distanziert sich von nichts betitelt werden kann. Ein Hitlergrossabstand. Ich finde ein einfaches Sorry, wo man kurz ins coole Englisch abdriftet. Ja, dann pardon, mein Gott. Entschuldigung. Ja, dann mea culpa. Ich kann alles, welche Sprache willst du? Nee, aber ich finde auch selbst so ein Entschuldigung reicht nicht. Nee, Ent muss schon sein. Keine Apostrophen. Nee. Keine einzige weit und breit. Kein Nennen, kein Nem, schreib's aus. Und deswegen, ich habe einige Verschwörungstheorie-Kanäle abonniert. Auch auf Facebook, gerade Facebook gibt es ja einige interessante Quellen. Und das heißt, ich über, tatsächlich immer, wenn was passiert in der Welt, überlege ich immer, ah, welchen Twist könnten jetzt Verschwörungstheoretiker finden, so. Und das ist immer ganz spannend zu gucken, was die tatsächlich machen und was man sich so selber überlegt hat. So, natürlich, klar, jetzt bei irgendwie Pharmaindustrie, das ist ja langweilig, so, das ist ja klar, das kommt ja immer. Aber jetzt ist eine Verschwörungstheorie, habe ich gelesen, ist, weil anscheinend jetzt ganz, also mehr Leute zu Hause sterben. Und die Zahl an häuslichen Toten hat zugenommen. Das ist ein riesiger Werbespot für die Bundesagentur für Familie. Ja, und das ist jetzt der neue Plan der Bevölkerungsauslöschung. Das ist ja generell so, auch Chemtrails und so wollen die Bevölkerung auslöschen. Und die Idee ist jetzt, die Leute an nach Hause zu bringen, damit die da sterben.
Ich finde gut, dass man nicht die naheliegende Lösung nimmt, der Virus tötet die Leute. Nee, den Virus gibt es ja nicht, ist ja klar, sondern der ist nur dazu da, um die Leute nach Hause zu treiben, wo es besonders gefährlich ist, zu Hause, und da sterben wie so Mäusefallen. Die werden da, wo sie dachten, sie sind sicher, nee, da sind sie besonders gefährdet. Und da sterben sie jetzt alle und so wird letztlich die Bevölkerung ausgerottet und dann und so weiter gibt es ja noch andere Spielarten, warum, aber das ist ja erstmal egal, Hauptsache die Bevölkerung wird ausgerottet. Finde ich total spannend. Finde ich auch spannend. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es dann ein bisschen fragwürdig, warum man nicht auf die naheliegende Idee kommt, zu sagen, der Virus kann ja, also es ist ja einfacher, Leute mit dem Virus umzubringen, als die Umstände zu Hause zu halten, bis sie mal irgendwann auf diese Wackelleiter klettern, wo man so runterfallen kann leicht. Ja, vor allem das ist einfach so ein leichter Gedanke, so dieses, oh,
häusliche Tode steigen, ist
die Corona-Hysterie übertrieben?
Und die Antwort lautet, nee,
wenn Leute mehr zu Hause sind,
dann sterben sie auch mehr zu Hause, weil
sie häufiger zu Hause sind.
Das ist es,
es sterben ja nicht mehr Leute, jetzt halt nur woanders
und wahrscheinlich haben die Verkehrsunfälle, gut, jetzt natürlich, wenn du sagst, die nehmen zu, dann wird mir da einiges an, wie sagt man hier, Benzin aus dem Kircher, keine Ahnung, naja, du verstehst schon. Ich hätte, nee, ich sag nicht. Wirf mal ein Seil, wirf mal eine Schlange zu. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
So eine Stoffschlange, wie heissen die?
Ich bin nicht mehr.
Diese aus Hanf gedrehten Schlangen.
Ich distanziere mich von diesem Gespräch.
Nee, nee, komm zurück.
Komplett. Du fährst mal eine Schlange zu, so eine Stoffschlange, wie heissen die? Ich bin nicht mehr. Diese aus Hanf gedrehten Schlangen.
Ich distanziere mich von diesem Gespräch.
Komm zurück, distanzier dich, komm zurück.
Ich kann dich gar nicht mehr hören.
Hör auf, nein, du darfst dich nicht so weit distanzieren, du bist zu weit weg.
Ich hab mich nicht mehr, ich kann dich nicht mehr hören.
Jetzt bist du zu weit, nee, das ist Quatsch, jetzt bist du zu weit.
Komplett distanzieren.
Distanzieren ist eines, aber nicht aus der Augenreichweite, so dass, sagt man ja Kindern,
so dass ich dich sehen kann. Aus der Augenreichweite finde ich auch nicht so schlecht. Damit das Augenlasso noch hinterherkommt, sozusagen, wie man im Western-Jargon sagt. Ja, aber das ist auf jeden Fall, damit verbringe ich meine Zeit. Ja, das ist eine gute Investition. Weißt du, es ist ja auch eine Art von kreativer Arbeit. Es ist ja so, also die denken sich das ja aus und überlegen sich das. Und es ist ja so ganz intuitiv. Ja, mir herrscht auch zu viel Einigkeit gerade. Ja, also ich bin das auch gewohnt so ein bisschen, auch das Internet ist es ja gewohnt, dass immer Diskurs am Laufen sind, ne? Streits. Ja. Äh, nee. Rechts gegen links, oben gegen unten, Arm gegen alt, B gegen A. Ja. a. Und jetzt gerade sind sich alle einig und haben einen gemeinsamen Feind. Finde ich schön auf der einen Seite, aber auch langweilig auf der anderen Seite. Ja, weil wir haben keine Konflikte mehr. Und deswegen freue ich mich ja über so ein paar Leute, die dann zumindest sagen, nee, aber den Virus gibt es gar nicht.
Alle, wir sollen zu Hause auf unseren Leiterchen sterben. Keine Glühbirne auswechseln, jetzt wirklich vorsichtig. Und unsere Glühbirnchen sterben. Das finde ich eine gute Idee, weil da habe ich das Gefühl, ah, endlich bildet sich mein Lager, wir haben ein bisschen Spaß. Ja. Aber alle sind sich so einig, alle hören diesen Podcast von Herrn Drosten, alle sind geupdatet, alle sind wissenschaftlich informiert, die Linken und die CDU, alle bei dem gleichen Gesetzesvorstoß jetzt dadurch und so, das ist alles mir zugleich. Wir müssen wieder ein bisschen Pfeffer reinbringen. Willst du derjenige sein, der jetzt die Gegenposition benimmt?
Willst du der Wosten sein,
der jetzt den Gegenpodcast macht oder was?
Ist das sein wie im Wosten
nichts Neues? Irgendwie so
einen schmissigen Titel? Ja, vielleicht schon.
Wobei, ich glaube, das würde mir
nicht gut stehen. Meinst du nicht?
Kleiner Image,
falsch abgebogen, in so einer Debatte
einfach mal viel zu früh,
viel zu falsch abgebogen.
Das kann, das darf man nicht machen.
Viel zu früh, meinst du, es geht noch lang?
Na, keine Ahnung.
Aber die Leute hören ja auch das Podcast-Ufo,
um davor zu fliehen.
Um die neuen Informationen zu wissen.
Es ist tatsächlich für mich immer schwierig, über solche Sachen zu reden.
Ja, und was hältst du davon? Ich habe keine Ahnung davon, nichts, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht mehr als andere. Wie Professor Doktor Jürgen Klopp, der Trainer des FC Liverpool, der auch gesagt hat, als er am Anfang gefragt wurde, wie es um Virus steht, hat er gesagt, sind Sie nicht bescheuert, einen Fussballtrainer zu fragen. Was ich sehr schön finde, dass endlich mal jemand, aber auf der anderen Seite alles andere ja auch, aber dann, ob die Abwehr jetzt gut stand oder nicht.
Was sollen wir die Ziele denn sonst fragen, von Fussball haben sie auch keine Ahnung.
Das können sie nicht machen, sie sind zum Fragen stellen.
Ja, als Kick halt.
Stand-up-Comedian hier ist.
Ich meine, wie lange sind sie jetzt im Fussballgeschäft, Herr Klopp? Gut und gerne, 30 Jahre. Da haben Sie doch jetzt schon jede Fussballfrage beantwortet. Was ist mit der Abwehr? Zumachen. Was ist mit dem Sturm? Schnelllaufen. Was ist mit dem Tor? Schießen. Ja, was ist mit dem Abseits? Lieber nicht. So, das haben wir doch jetzt alles durch. Ich meine, seit fünf Jahren, seien wir mal ehrlich, diese Pressekonferenzen haben ein bisschen ihren Reiz verloren, finden Sie nicht. Das war früher mal ein bisschen mehr drin. Ist das Ihre Frage? Sie haben eine Frage. Okay, dann nehme ich die Frage zurück, dann will ich gerne eine andere Frage nehmen. War die Abwehr, stand die Abwehr gut. Warum ist die Abwehr nicht zu, Herr Klopp?
Macht sie dir doch zu, Mann.
Das ist doch, das ist aber eine gute Frage.
Aber das stimmt schon. Fussballfragen sind
irgendwann auch erschöpft. Mittlerweile wurden,
ich verstehe auch nicht, wie die allen Ernstes
immer noch diese Field Reporter
da hinschicken können, um nach dem
Spiel
Interviews zu führen, weil das klafft immer aufs Gleiche
hinaus, es ist immer albern.
Du kannst vorher den Fernseher ausmachen und über die Lippen
Vielen Dank. dahin schicken können, um nach dem Spiel Interviews zu führen, weil es klappt immer aufs Gleiche hinaus, es ist immer albern, du kannst vorher den Fernseher ausmachen und über die Lippen sprechen und es würde passen, weil du genau weißt, was du machen kannst. Kannst du bei Animal Crossing auch. Aber ich glaube auch, dass sich das langsam wechseln wird, also dass man andere Gesprächsthemen findet. Das ist jetzt halt, so ein Sport ist ja auch wie ein Date. So, die ersten Minuten klappert man halt so das ab, ja, Geschlechtskrankheiten, ja, nein, so. Aber dann kommen andere Gesprächsthemen, dann kommt so, ah, okay, was glaubst du, Columbus war wirklich in Amerika? Oder wie dick war der dick oder nicht? Weil auf so einem Schiff bewegt man sich da viel und wie viel haben die gegessen? Also kann es sein, dass der halt zurückkommt aus Amerika und alle sagen, Kolumbus, wohl eher Kolumbetsack. Glaubst du, das war ein Team? Kugelumbus. Kugelumbus, ja. Okay, nicht schlecht. Ne, ja, ne. Und glaubst du nicht, dass das seinen Ruhm irgendwie so überlagert hat? Dass er sagt, ich habe Amerika gefunden und also, oh, du hast ja auch Marsregel gefunden und halt sowas. Meinst du nicht? Kann schon gut sein. Ist Christoph Columbus der mit der Mayflower gefahren ist? Nein. Nein, das waren ja die Übersiedler, die Amerikaner, die späteren Amerikaner. Columbus hat es ja erst entdeckt. Mayflower kamen dann die ersten Setter. Nee, nee. Hab mich kurz verrannt. Christoph Columbus hat es entdeckt, aber auch nicht wirklich. Er wollte Indien. Nee, er wollte nicht Indien suchen, hat dann Amerika gefunden. Er hat Indien gesucht und Amerika gefunden, so wie wir ein bisschen. Das ist ja ein Riesendepp. Ja. Weil er es hat Indien nicht gefunden, hat Amerika gefunden, er hat es trotzdem Indien genannt. F Finde mal Indien und fahr, der ist ja einfach blind links irgendwo hingefahren, hat gesagt, da ist bestimmt Indien. Er ist dann komplett in die falsche Richtung gefahren. Du, ich habe noch einen Termin später, ich habe noch eine Podcastaufnahme, ich mache so einen True Crime Podcast und da muss ich los jetzt. Du musst jetzt los? Ich muss jetzt los, ja. Für den True-Crime-Podcast? Ja, ich muss jetzt leider los. Wir haben da diesen einen der Familienvater, wo man am Anfang dachte, oh, der hat doch das perfekte Leben, Frau, Kinder, guten Job und man denkt so, okay, ist ja das perfekte Leben eigentlich, was kann das noch zerstören? Richtig. Und dann Mord. Mord, na klar, Mord. Hat da jemanden umgebracht, aber es ist halt nicht klar, ob das wirklich war oder nicht. Und dann ist es so jede Folge mal klar, mal nicht klar. Genau. Ich stehe schon mal auf und sage Tschüss und wir sehen uns, vielleicht sehen wir uns nochmal auf auf Tinder, ansonsten macht's gut, tschau. Tschüss Herr Klopp. Wir verwirren, du guckst. War das Ihre Frage jetzt? War das Ihre Frage? Wollen Sie? Nee, die Abwehr stand sicherlich zu hoch hier und da. Und beim Gegenpressing hat es nicht so gekannt. Löcher drin wie ein Schweizer Käse. Klappt wie Entschuldigung. Aber diesen Podcast, wo kann ich den Podcast hören? Äh, Podigy, Spodigy. Warum reden Sie mal höher? Oder im Web www so ein perfektes Leben, was könnte es zerstören? Ein Mord? Fragezeichen. Es war ein Mord. Ja, ja, schon. .de slash, ja, es war ein Mord. Ja, voll. Ein Mord. Oh, mir wurde wieder eine Website angeboten. Gross, gross, grossartig. Ich kriege manchmal diese Mails, wollen Sie nicht diese Website kaufen, weil ich hab schon mal eine Website gekauft für tatsächlich nicht wenig Geld. Ich hab, hab ich ja schon mal erzählt, ich wollte eine Website haben und dann war die aber schon verkauft und dann muss man ja jemanden anschreiben und der sagt, ich hab die, ich hab die, ha ha ha und du nicht. Landlord. Genau, das ist so ein Herr, der sitzt da auf dieser Webseite in so einem Schaukelstuhl mit so einer Pfeife. Ich nehme mir so ein fetter Drache vor. Der ist so ein Goldschatz, so Smaug-artig. Ah, du kommst zu mir! Du kommst ausgerechnet zu mir, um die Website Tickelbrink zu kaufen. Ja, was ist dir Tickelbrink wert? Und dann habe ich verhandelt und dann meinte der, ja, ich will 1000 Euro. Er hat gesagt, ja, ich habe 50. Und er hat gesagt, na, nee. Und dann ging es immer so weiter, dann ist er auf 500 und ich habe gesagt, 50, 200, na, ich habe halt 50. So bist du, so verhandelst du. So bin ich und er hat gesagt, wochen später wieder zurückgeschrieben, ja mach mal hundert.
Und ich so, ich habe fünfzig. Und wochen später schreibt er, ja okay, fünfzig. Nicht mehr. Und so sind wir von tausend Euro auf fünfzig runtergekommen. Und jetzt bin ich anscheinend in so einer Kartei drin von Leuten, die Websites kaufen. The art of the deal. Ja, oder das. So genau, so, so Rookie-Webseitenverkäufer müssen sich erst mal an mir die Zähne ausbeißen. Wenn du den kriegst, dann kriegst du alle. Wenn du dem 100 Euro abluckst, dann kommst du hier in so eine Hall of Fame. Und jetzt werden mir ab und zu Webseiten angeboten. Und das sind die obskursten Webseiten, die eben da angeboten werden, weil bietet mal jemand eine Webseite an, was er so gebrauchen könnte. Ja, das ist ja echt die Bedürfnisse sind ja sehr, sehr eng und aber sehr schöne Webseite wurde mir angeboten. Ich glaube, die habe ich mal gegoogelt, daher kommen die und mir wurde angeboten, hey, haben Sie Interesse an Worstbird.com? Worstbird? Worstbird.com.
Ehrlich gesagt, du bist ein Idiot, wenn du Worstbird.com nicht kaufst.
Ich dachte mir, ist das die fucking beste Website der Welt?
Worstbird?
Erstmal ist es ein unglaublich, unglaublich toller, sich reimender ...
Ja, es klingt gut, Worstbird. Genau, und darüber hinaus kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass du da auf der Seite landest und da ist immer jeden Monat das Bild eines Vogels. Der schlechteste Vogel der Welt. Ja, genau so etwas habe ich mir auch überlegt. Ich will die Website haben und ich will da dann irgendwie worstbird.com halt richtig gross machen. Das ist so wirklich so Google, Facebook, Amazon, worstbird, einfach so die fünf Uhr. Worst bad. Im deutschen Schwierig nicht so schön zu sagen, worst bad. Worst bad. Aber es stimmt schon, weil du hast dieses war, ist ja so ein bisschen i, war, bur. Das ist sehr ähnlich, obwohl es zwei unterschiedliche Buchstaben sind, Wörr's Bird, obwohl es ein O und I ist. Das klingt total toll. Können wir vielleicht, wenn wir noch die Tizze will, GbR, wo wir beide, wir standen nie so richtig hinter dem Namen. Mein Vorschlag wäre jetzt, dass unsere Produktionsfirma Wörr's Bird war. Vor allem die erste Mail, die wir jemals an dieses GbR-Unternehmen, keine Ahnung, Amt schicken, so Mail eins, hallo, wir wollen Titzewill, zwei Jahre später, hallo, wir würden uns gerne umbenennen, Worst Bird. Was ist in zwei Jahren bei Ihnen passiert? Ja, genau. Was ist von der guten Alte? Wir haben erst Unterhaltung. Ja. Aber Sie sind schon noch immer Unterhaltungsdienstleister, oder? Aber finde ich sehr gut. Also, worstbird.com ist ab sofort ... Lass uns da gerne unsere Website draus machen. Und zwar, worstbird wurde mir angeboten von Kate. Kate hat mir geschrieben, Domain Name Broker. Kate ist Domain Name Broker und hat mir geschrieben.
Die beste, der beste Domain Name Broker der Welt. Ja, hat mir geschrieben, would you be interested in worsebird.com und sie hat mir auch tatsächlich schon einen Preisoffer gemacht und zwar 295 Dollar. Das ist nicht so viel. Will sie für Worst Bird oder zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder 295 Dollar. Das ist nicht so viel. Will sie für Worst Bird oder, zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder 295 Dollar oder 10 mal 29 Dollar. Also das lässt sie mir offen. Ich verstehe nicht genau, was sie davon hat, 10 mal 90, 222. Ja, in kleinen Scheinen halt so. Das ist ein bisschen schwierig. Kannst du immer schreiben, we have 50 dollars. Genau, ich habe schon zurückgeschrieben, habe gesagt, hey Kate, I'm very interested, but I only have 50 dollars. Und jetzt versuche ich, meine Strategie genauso wieder zu verwenden. Und einfach zu sagen, ich habe geschrieben, ich weiß nicht, ob das so klug war, ich habe geschrieben, I'm an Indie-Music-Producer and I only have 50 dollars, weil dann dachte ich mir so, okay, der hat nicht viel Geld, aber als Indie-Musik-Produzent, der braucht eine Webseite und weil dann dachte ich mir, was denkt sie denn, dass ich schon Worst Bird heiße und jetzt die Webseite dazu will oder dass ich mir aufgrund ihres Vorschlags mich in Worst Bird umdenen, es ist merkwürdig. Ich finde das faszinierend, dass es das gibt allein. Es ist fantastisch, vor allem manchmal bist du ja von. Aber welche Seite hast du nochmal gekauft, kannst du das sagen? Ich sag mal so, es ist ein deutsches Wort, einfach ein deutsches Wort.de. Weil sie ist, aber ist es absurd, weil ich glaube, hat sie, ist sie sichsten Note, die WorstBird.com ausstrahlt, bewusst? Ich weiß nicht, du, das könnten alles automatisch generierte Mails sein, ich habe keine Ahnung, aber es ist manchmal so spannend, weil du bist manchmal nur eine Mail davon entfernt, Teil einer komplett fremden Welt zu sein. Ich bin jetzt im Domain Broker Business und anscheinend werde ich so als... Nee, du bist vom Domain Broker Business ausgenutzt. Ja, das stimmt. Und du bist auch bereit, 50 Dollar zu zahlen. Und vor allem, wenn du jedem noch jemandem schreibst, du hast 50 Dollar, vor allem irgendwann, wenn er so oft 50 Dollar hat, hat er vielleicht mehr. Mehr als 50 Dollar. Streng genommen hat er seine 50 Dollar sogar schon ausgegeben für deutschernahme.de. Vielleicht hat er sogar zehnmal 50 Dollar. Wer weiss. Ich stelle mir nur so vor, dass ich bei denen im Büro ist so ein Poster von mir mit so Dartpfeilen drin, sodass ich so, okay, das ist der Geldsack, den drücken wir aus. 50 Dollar, wie oft kriegen wir noch 50 Dollar? Das war der erste Akt eines Films, wo am Ende dann, wo jemand den Traum hat, Domain-Name-Broker zu werden.
Ja.
Da kommt dann dieses grosse Büro und da hängt dann so ein grosses Bild von dir.
Ja, genau.
Und dann ist es die Frage, hey, who is he? dann, wo jemand den Traum hat, Domain Name Broker zu werden, da kommt dann dieses grosse Büro und da hängt dann so ein grosses Bild von dir.
Und dann ist es die Frage, hey, who is he?
Genau, hat man so einen Mentor und dann ist es die Frage, wer ist er?
He's Worst Bird.
This is Worst Bird.
It's Worst Bird.
Not allowed to say the name.
Und der Film heisst natürlich auch Worst Bird.
Ja, genau.
Deswegen bricht im Kino so ein Getuschel aus. Ja, ja, dieses Rollcredits an alle, die Cinema-Sins kennen und denken, sie sind lustig. Gut. Aber, falls ihr eine neue Website sucht, geht mal auf worstbird.com. Ich hoffe, dass ich die Website habe, bevor die Folge online geht. Das sollten wir hinkriegen. Und dann seht ihr ein Bild vom schlechtesten Vogel. Aber ist das nicht so schlecht? Also wir können ja auch unsere Kontaktdaten hinschreiben, falls man eine Podcast-Produktion von Worst Bird Productions haben will. Ja. Und dann nehmen immer der schlechteste Vogel. Und dann brauchen wir noch so einen Abbinder. This podcast was presented to you by Worst Bird. Worst Bird. Worst Bird. Worst Bird. Vor allem, ich glaube, mein Steuerberater wird sich auch freuen, so, Herr Will, ich brauche jetzt unbedingt noch die Rechnungsunterlagen von 2017. Und ich so, übrigens, wir haben jetzt unsere GbR umbenannt in Worst Bird. Prioritäten, Junge, Prioritäten. Ich fahre noch die von 2006 und du benennst dich um. Ja. Aber dann sag ich, ist ja praktisch dann. Wenn die E noch fehlt, können sie direkt rückdatieren. Genau, ja. Auf Warsburg Limit. Wir stossen Tietze und Will ab. Wie gesagt, ich war von dem Namen Indie begeistert. Weil wie gesagt, der Coole steht immer vorne. Asterix und Obelix, Tim und Struppi, Tietze und Will, aber gut, das war deine Entscheidung,
du hast den Namen. Aber mein Vorschlag auch.
Mein Vorschlag war Tietze, die W.
Da warst du gegen.
Tietze und Co.
Drop the Will,
hat Klasse Timberlake gesagt.
Tietze und Co.
Just make it Tietze, drop the Will.
Drop the Will.
Drop the worst, just name it Bird. Drop the Will, ist auch echt generell. Just drop it, drop the will. Drop the will. Drop the will. Drop the worst. Just name it Bird. Drop the will ist auch echt generell gut. Just drop it. Drop the will. Man kann, vielleicht gibt es auch noch The Worst Bird. Das ist dann die Konkurrenz. The Worst Bird gegen Worst Bird. Worst Bird ist besser. Ja, Worst Bird ist viel besser. Aber wir müssen mal unsere, ich habe mit einem Freund eine Top-100-Liste gemacht, Filme. Wir haben beide unsere Top-100-Lieblingsfilme jeweils aufgeschrieben. Und dann haben wir da, weil er wohnt in Hamburg, ich wohne in Köln, deswegen sieht man sie nicht so häufig, schreibt halt ab und zu mal. Haben uns dann immer so über bestimmt, was war das, so anderthalb Monate verteilt, jeden Tag mal so einen Film gedroppt, die nächste Nummer auf unserer Liste.
Ach so, von unten hochgezählt. Von unten hochgezählt, bis wir nach Monaten dann bei der Eins gelandet waren. Und es war eine echt coole Zeit. Also erstmal, solche Listen machen wahnsinnig viel Spaß zu erstellen. Nicht im Sonnens gibt es in jedem Podcast so Top Five, das ist ja auch immer normal. Deswegen sind wir auf Top drei gegangen. Genau, weil wir fucking Worshers sind. Eben. Und das macht erstens Spaß, Listen zu erstellen und zweitens kommt man darauf ganz tolle Filme und lernt viele tolle Filme kennen, die die anderen noch nicht kennen. Weil bei 100, da muss man sich auch, das ist auch cool für sich selber, weil man sich selber reflektiert und anfängt irgendwie, man will ja auch was ausstrahlen damit. Du lernst sehr viel über dich selber kennen, wenn du merkst, ah, ein Film, ist Citizen Kane, den du nicht magst, aber dann trotzdem ganz oben schreibst, weil du willst ja auch irgendwie ein cooles Bild von dir erzeugen. Du lernst wahnsinnig viel über dich, auch deine schlechten Seiten lernst du über diese Listen kennen und deswegen unbedingt diese Listen machen und jetzt für die Zeit auch ganz cool, weil man sehr viele Filme gucken kann. Ich glaube, bei 100 Filmen wäre ich schon so weit, dass ich denke, mir fallen 112 Filme ein. Also eigentlich ist die Arbeit eher, welche 12 schaue nicht so gern. Und alle anderen kommen in die Liste. Ja, genau. Weil bei hundert Filmen, ich habe letztens ja, ich bin ja mittendrin, meine DVDs zu digitalisieren, und da finde ich manche Perlen, weil ich habe immer über Amazon bestellt. Und es war so die Endphase der DVD, wo im Amazon UK hast du teilweise einen Film für zwei Cent bekommen. Also wirklich fast nichts. Du musstest eigentlich nur Porto zahlen. Und wenn du halt ganz viele gekauft hast, dann war das halt fast kostenlos. Dann zahlst du halt dann irgendwie 20 Pfund für 30, 40 Filme oder so, wahnsinnig viel. Und dann bist du halt in so einem Klickrausch und klickst dir das alles durch zusammen und haust da auch Filme rein, die du eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt sehen willst, aber ich denke jetzt, die kosten halt zwei Cent, was nimmt man nicht für zwei Cent mit, was muss ein Regisseur machen, damit man sagt, zwei Cent für einen, ja, aber zwei, nee, und dann habe ich was durchgeklickt und jetzt habe ich ein bisschen aussortiert. Und die schönste DVD, die ich gefunden habe, war The Unauthorized Biography of J.K. Rowling. Wann die Sinn? Unauthorized. Und ich dachte mir, alles, was mit Unauthorized beginnt, gib mir her damit. Ja, will ich sehen. Aber warum ist es nicht autorisiert? Aber warum ist es erschienen? Ja, gute Frage, warum ist es erschienen? Wieso kann etwas Unauthorisiertes erscheinen? Ist da nicht irgendwo ein Paradoxon? Da weiss es nicht, hat der Fuchs in den Schwanz. Vielleicht darf man es nur veröffentlichen, wenn man dazu schreibt, dass es the unauthorized, hated by and hopefully soon to be forgot. Also Biografien, die nicht gehatet sind bei den Leuten, gucke ich auch gar nicht. Nee, du willst ja den Juicy Shit. Genau, und vor allem diese Biografie, es ist nicht wirklich eine Biografie. Hast du geschaut? Ich habe es auch geschaut, ja. Naja, sagen wir Biografie. Was heißt Biografie?
Es ist ein Mensch.
Ist sie in Hufflepuff gewesen?
Nein, J.K. Rowling ist in dieser Dokumentation kein einziges Mal zu sehen.
Null Prozent. Ja, weil sie alles nicht autorisiert hat.
Null Prozent Screentime. Und woraus dieser Film letzten Endes besteht ...
Sind Freunde, die über J.K. Rowling sind.
Sind nicht mal Freunde, sondern ...
Fans.
Nachbarn.
Ah, ja gut, aber du willst eher Nachbarn als Freunde.
Naja, aber anscheinend hat eine Person gesagt,
okay, ich mache einen Film über J.K. Rowling.
Ruft J.K. Rowling an, Absage. Shit.
Ruft Daniel Radcliffe an, Absage. Fuck. Christopher Columbus, Absage. Okay, wir haben niemanden. Aber was machen wir? Okay, pass auf, wir fahren einfach in die Geburtsstadt von J.K. Rowling, gucken auf Wikipedia nach und fragen random Leute, bis wir wissen, wo sie gewohnt hat, wo sie gewohnt hat und fragen sie dann, haben sie J.K. Rowling schon mal gesehen? Und die Antwort laut meistens natürlich, nee. Bei den waren die ganzen Nähs auch in dem Film. Da waren Nähs nicht, aber so ein Ah, ich habe gehört, dass sie aus dieser Stadt kommt. Toll, was Harry Potter so viele junge Leute Harter Schnitt. Harter Schnitt. Toll mit ihrem Lord of the Rings. Ciao, ja. Und das ist ein grossartiger Film. Und das ist wirklich so, das ist einfach ein paar schöne Filme. Was haben denn die Nachbarn bei sich, wo ist sie denn gewohnt? Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der Ort heißt, aber das kann man wahrscheinlich auf Wikipedia nachgucken. Ja, genau. Glaubst du, das ist ein Vorort von London oder so? Ja, irgendwie sowas. Glaub ich, auch keine, nicht so krasse Verhältnisse, also ich glaube schon ziemlich, also keine guten Verhältnisse, ich glaube, also so ein bisschen uncooler vor Ort, also kein Schickimicki vor Ort von unten, glaube ich. Und dann haben Nachbarn sie als, hat damals Klavier gelernt, super nerviges Kind, so betitelt. Niemand kannte sie persönlich, das heißt, der Stoff ist so dünn, dass man wirklich nach fünf Minuten Mitleid hat. Was war der Klappentext auf der DVD? Ja, Never Before Seen Interviews und The Whole Story of the Acclaimed Author, Name nicht genannt, der steht nur einmal auf dem Cover drauf. Also wirklich so schäbig, schäbig, schäbig, aber ich hatte grossen Spaß und du denkst immer so, komm, findet jemanden, bitte, du hast so Mitleid mit diesem Film, weil es so schlecht ist.
Das wäre aber auch so geil, wenn das so abdriftet, dann plötzlich und die alle, diese ganzen Nachbarn über den einen weirden Nachbarn sprechen, den sie haben.
Ja, genau. Ach so, sie sind wegen J.K. Rowling hier, ja, die ist hier wohl aufgewachsen. Ich dachte schon, sie wären wegen Herrn Mr. Miller hier am Ende der Strasse, weil der ist ja seit Wochen, verschwinden hier Menschen und alle sind sich sicher, dass der was war. Und dann geht das dritte so ab. Die erste Person, die Sie interviewen, ist Mr. Miller. Und danach alle weiteren erzählen nur über Mr. Miller und dann von wegen so, wie, der lebt ja doch seit Jahren nicht mehr. Wie, Sie haben mit dem gesprochen? Niemand hat mit dem gesprochen. Und der Mr. Miller ist der Erste, der so, ja, Jackie Rowling habe ich gesehen, ah, kein Problem, und dann so, Mr. Miller, und dann recherchiert sie, Mr. Miller ist vor drei Jahren gestorben. Aber wir haben ihn hier auf Band. Und dann zoomt man so rein und dann ... Muss man dann nicht überlegen, aber ... Es ist halt Autoren, was schreiben. Ja, klar. Das ist ... Ja, dann schreibt er dann schon, das ist kein Buch. Ja, dann schreibt er dann schon. Ja, dann schreibt er, haben da ein paar gute junge Leute, die schreiben das an. Die schreiben uns das weg. Schreiben uns das ohne. Aber als Podcast, so als Interview-Podcast, so berühmte Leute aus meiner Stadt. Wer ist berühmte Leute aus meiner Stadt? Und dann fragt man so rum und dann erzählen die einer was. Sabine Heinrich. Ja, aus Carmen, Sabine Heinrich? Glaube ich, Carmen, Carmen, derne, glaube ich, bin mir nicht so sicher. Ein Vorort von Carmen. Ja, aber das stimmt, es gibt gerade viele, ich habe auch überlegt mit einer Freundin, es wäre sehr lustig, wenn man jetzt, finde ich einen sehr guten Film, über diese Zeit jetzt hier, weil man mit Leuten plötzlich, man darf ja ein paar Premium-Kontakte haben gerade. Wie viele? Zwei maximal, hat die Tagesschau gesagt. Premium-Kontakte sind Kontakte, mit denen man dann ab und zu mal reden kann, die abhängen können bei dir auch, mit denen man sich treffen kann. Leute, mit denen man eh schon viel Zeit verbracht hat und man auch wahrscheinlich sich angesteckt hätte, wenn man schon hätte und so weiter. Die darf man haben, mit denen darf man sich weiter treffen, die darf man weiter sehen, die darf man auch rausgehen, quasi wie Leute, die eine WG haben. Das sind dann dann dann Premium-Kontakte oder Familie. Und das wäre eigentlich ganz lustig, finde ich, ein Film, der halt in so einer Situation anfängt, und dann kommt aber irgendwann raus, dass dein Premium-Kontakt vorgaukelt, dass da draußen noch ein Virus herrscht.
Aha.
Und das wäre so Ende, Ende Akt eins, wäre dann, holy shit, diese Person wollte einfach nur wahnsinnig viel Zeit bei mir verbringen.
Ja.
Aber es gibt diesen Virus da draußen gar nicht mehr, da draußen ist alles normal. Okay, und was ist denn Akt zwei? Was passiert dann? Flucht, vor wem? Akt zwei, vor der Person. Das ist so eine Stalker-Geschichte. Stalker-Geschichte, weil die einen weiter bei sich behalten will. Und Akt drei ist dann, ah, nee, Stocker-Syndrom. Man hat sich ja dann doch verliebt, kommt zurück. dann leben sie wieder zurück. Irgendwas schlecht, nach einer Flucht, die den kompletten zweiten Akt gefüllt hat, zu sagen, jetzt müssen wir wieder zurück. So jetzt zurück. Bisschen unbefriedigend für den Zuschauer, aber... Nö, ist ja egal. Nö? Nö. Nö, finde ich eine gute Idee. Nö, ist ja eine Liebestory. Ach so. Na, am Ende gewinnt die Liebe. Aber was für ein Drama, oder? Also, wie man kann ja nicht bewusster Streit sähen, als zu sagen, jeder von euch kriegt zwei Freundschaftsbändchen, gebt ihr euren besten Freunden und du weißt, die ganze Klasse explodiert nach zwei Tagen. Ja. Ich finde, die sadistischste Erfindung der Menschheit ist Freundschaftsbändchen. Wie pervers ist das denn, ein abstraktes Konzept wie Freundschaft in so eine scheiß Kordel zu manifestieren und zu sagen, ich gebe dir mein Freundschaftsbändchen, nur um allen zu zeigen, dass du jetzt schon befreundet bist? Bei uns war es ja kein Ding mehr. Ich glaube, das ist auch eher was unter Mädchen. Also habe ich zumindest die Erfahrung gemacht, als ich Zivi mit Kindern gemacht habe, war das bei den Mädchen immer ganz wichtig und dann macht man Freundschaftsbändchen und du gibst dir Freundschaftsbändchen nicht um deine Freundinnen zu beglücken, sondern um alle anderen zu sagen, du bist nicht meine Freundin und dann geht das Drama los und ich dachte mir in der Zeit nur so, so viel Leid, so viel Leid in der Welt, in unserer Gruppe. Da kam der große Scherenmann, der hat Florentin mit der Schere, hat die Freundschaftsbändchen durchgeschnitten.
Und befreit, das sind die Fessel, die Fessel der Kindheit, sind diese Freundschaftsbändchen, schrecklich.
Wir mögen Florentin nicht so gern, kann der nicht mehr auf uns aufpassen, bitte?
Schip, schip, schip, schip, schip, schip, schip.
Er redet die ganze Zeit, er will uns von den Fesseln befreien.
Die Fesseln der sozialen Drucks und Konventionen! Legt die Fesseln ab, bäumt euch auf, Vorschülerinnen! Dann sollen wir uns immer auf seinen Schoß setzen. Das hast du falsch verstanden. Hat er gesagt? Nein, habe ich nicht gesagt. Das war mal das Schlimmste, wenn Kinder sich verletzt haben und man dann so, und dann man geholt wurde von einem anderen Kind, also ich habe Zivilenst bei Kindern gemacht, und dann wurde man geholt so, ah, die Lisa hat sich verletzt.
Und dann gehst du da halt hin und dann ist halt Lisa aufs Knie gefallen und weint und hält sich das Knie und denkst dir, was, also entweder, also es gibt keine Option für mich gerade, ich kann nichts machen. Ich kann es aber die Arwen machen, die Hand drauflegen, überhavern. Lethalon, Kerr, ja, da kommen sie diese Wasserpferde, ups, ups, und Leon weggespült. Hey, Leon ist der Trunk, Leon ist von einer Wasserherde, Pferdeherde angefallen. Meine Magie ist nicht stark genug, wir müssen sie zu Elrond bringen. Da, glaube ich, hätten die Kinder Bock drauf. Herr Elrond. Herr Elrond. Aber das war auch immer so Hilflosigkeit, vollständige Hilflosigkeit. Und am Ende hast du dann wirklich irgendwie irgendwie dann so ein Verband rumgemacht oder halt irgendwas Placebomässiges, einfach nur um was gemacht zu haben. Weil letzten Endes checkt das Kind ja auch nicht, ob das jetzt was hilft oder nicht. Und dann macht man halt teilweise auch einfach Bullshit so und gibt denen halt dann irgendwie so eine Vitamintablette oder so und sagt, davon ist sein Knie jetzt und ja, kurz geht's mir oder besser so. Was soll man machen? Ich finde es gruselig, die Welt wird gruselig, wenn man derjenige ist, der gerufen wird, wenn man nicht mehr derjenige sein darf, der irgendwo hingeht, um Hilfe zu holen. Ja, stimmt, ja. Da wird die Welt gruselig, dreht sich um und da macht es auch dann keinen Spaß mehr. Deswegen gehe ich immer noch gerne in Holhilfe. Ich bin gesagt, sehr gerne hole ich Hilfe. Ja, oh, ich hole Hilfe. Du trägst es nur weiter, du bist so ein Domino. Nee, ich nutze die Zeit, um wegzuremnen.
Oh, ich hole Hilfe.
Ja.
Klettersau.
Viel zu leistungsstarkes Auto.
Ja.
Dann rast er über die leeren Strassen davon. Aber es stimmt schon, man kann jetzt mittlerweile auch oft auf den Strassen laufen, was wirklich so ein I am Robot. Und es kommen diese, nee, I am Legend weißt du. Achso, I am Legend. Und es kommen diese Wüstenbälle. Ja,, Tumbleweed. Tumbleweed-artige Dinge habe ich jetzt schon gesehen. Ja. Wie die dann so klischee-mäßig über ... Warum hört das dann irgendwann auf? Warum liegt irgendwann so was auf der Strasse, solche Dinge, die sich dann so rüberrollen? Weil es ist ja sinnbildlich für leere Strassen. Aber es räumt ja auch niemand weg, wenn die Strassen voll sind, denke ich mir. Im Gegenteil, es müsste doch mehr Dreck geben, wenn viele Leute auf den Beinen sind. Aber wenn es so leer ist, liegt dann plötzlich Dreck auf der Strasse. Wann fängt das an? Und wann fangen wir an, uns so Frisuren zu machen wie bei Madman? Meinst du, das ist der nächste Schritt? Ja, wann fängt das? Das kommt, dass wir beim Arzt wieder ruhussgetrinken? Wann startet der Prozess? Und wie startet man den Prozess? Wie startet der Prozess, dass Tumbleweed sich bildet auf der Strasse und so Tüten rumfliegen? Wer sammelt die sonst ein? Oder es ist einfach so, es muss jetzt so sein, weil die Strassen sind leergefegt und wir sind eine Art Film. Ich glaube, das ist so eine Kettenreaktion. Wann kommt der Balken oben, diese Filmbalken von unten und oben rein. Ja, genau. Wann wird es so grisselig, so 35 mm. Wann kommt Hans Zimmer? Ja. Werbung. Floritin, sag mal deine Lieblingsfilme. Mulan, König der Löwen und Star Wars Clone Wars. Und was haben die alle gemeinsam? Verdammt gute Filme, spannend. Völlig richtig, aber ist doch alles von Disney. Und all das kannst du jetzt auf Disney Plus gucken. Ist es endlich da? Lange warten wir schon drauf. Alles das kannst du gucken und viele Serien, unter anderem The Mandalorian. Yes. Tolle Serie, auch in diesem Podcast besprochen worden. Und weißt du, was das Beste ist? Du kannst alle Sachen auch gleichzeitig gucken. Alle vier Sachen, die du gerade aufgezählt hast, kannst du gleichzeitig gucken. Du bist auf bis zu vier Screens gleichzeitig. Ich kann Mulan auf vier Screens gleichzeitig schauen. Wie gut ist das denn? Wir haben auch schon The Mandalorian besprochen, auch das gibt es natürlich da exklusiv, das ganze Marvel-Universum, also tobt euch aus und viel Spaß mit Disney+. Und weiterhin mit der Folge. Werbung. Jetzt ist die Möglichkeit, Trends zu setzen, weil niemand hat eine Ahnung, was hilft. Das ist eine unsichtbare Bedrohung, niemand hat eine Ahnung. Ich glaube, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel anfängt, mit einem Cape rumzulaufen, du gehst normal einkaufen und trägst einen Cape, aber halt so über die Schultern. Das ist Podcast UFO TM Tape. Richtig.
Cape, zum Beispiel im Shop von 1999.
Das ist so ein Cape und irgendwann denkt man sich, ich träg einen Cape.
Können wir bitte einen Cape verkaufen?
Eigentlich schon, ja.
Gerne.
Aber mit dem UFO drauf, oder was?
Aber ist es nicht gefährlich, dass Leute dann
von irgendwo runterspringen und sterben?
Warum? Naja, auf so einem Superman-Kostüm steht immer drauf, nicht ermöglicht es dir nicht zu fliegen, Depp.
Aber das denken Leute bei dem Podcast-Sofashop einkaufen.
Du, ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, da springen Leute vom Baum und sterben einfach.
Aber eigentlich eine gute Idee, weil ich glaube, jetzt kannst du sowas Trendsetten.
Und dann, weil du denkst, ja, jetzt fangen auch schon Leute an, Masken sich zu basteln selber, wo ich mir denke, jetzt ist die Frage, wer wollen wir sein, was ist unsere Mad Max Welt, die können wir uns gerade bauen. Genau, ja, Mad Max hat einen guten Weg genommen, die sind halt cool, so Rock und irgendwie schwere Maschinen und so, Cyberpunk, aber es läuft jetzt halt echt in eine lame Richtung gerade, muss man ja auch mal sehr kritisch sagen. es läuft in so eine Jack-Wolfskin-Richtung. Was definitiv nicht die richtige Richtung ist. Ja, in the North Face. Ich meine, diese Masken bieten natürlich jetzt auch so eine Superheldenrichtung an, dass man jetzt sagt, okay, man trägt halt farbige Masken über die Augen so irgendwie und dann hat man halt so Superheldenfiguren, blau und rot. Und wenn dann noch die Capes hinzukommen, dann glaube ich, kann das eine ganz interessante Richtung noch nehmen. Wenn jetzt mal alle Podcast-Sufe-Hörer einkaufen gehen mit einem Cape und irgendwann denkt man sich, warum tragen die alle Cape? Und dann fängt man auch an, Cape zu tragen und dann entwickelt sich das so weiter und niemand weiß warum, aber alle geben sich so eine Erklärung wie ja, das wirbelt irgendwie die Luft auf und dadurch bla bla bla in so ein Bullshit. Und ich glaube, dadurch kann man richtig neue Trends einsetzen. Ja, genau. Vielleicht sind das sogar, ja. Oder halt diese Bälle, diese grossen Bälle, in denen man laufen kann. Ja, aber damit kommst du halt nirgendwo mehr rein. So ein U-Bahn-Eingang, so Dotz, Dotz. Oder machst du ein Hole in one einfach. Warum brauchst du eine U-Bahn? Du brauchst keine U-Bahn mehr. Du bist ja auch schneller, oder nicht? Vielleicht auch nicht. Man ist glaube ich nicht etwa genauso schnell wie sonst auch. Ey, damit ist mal jemand vom Berg gefallen. Aber ist ja nicht schlimm. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es schlimm ist. Ich glaube, es gibt schon Grenzen. Na klar gibt es Grenzen, jemand platzt es. Im Kern ist es ein Luftballon, ein grosser Luftballon. Es hat schon Grenzen. Das hast du gerade ganz ernst und traurig betroffen gesagt. Ist ein Verwandter von dir in so einem Gummiball gestorben? Nee, aber ich überlege gerade, es muss ja Sachen geben, weil du, wenn du irgendwo aus dem Flugzeug springst, du wirst ja immer schneller, aber irgendwann nicht mehr. Irgendwann wirst du nicht mehr schneller, sondern hast eine, und wenn du es schaffst, irgendwas zu haben, wo du dann in dieser Geschwindigkeit noch überlebst, dann schaffst du ja alles, dann ist ja egal, wofür du runterfällst.
Also es muss ja eine Grenze geben, es gibt ja eine Grenze. Man muss halt nur die Grenze ausreizen. Man muss einen sehr großen Ball aus Helium, wo dann irgendwann die Gravitation den Luftwiderstand ausgleicht. Ja. Umgekehrt. Ja. Ja, aber es entwickeln sich dramatische Endzeit-Szenarien. Und es war wirklich ein bisschen körbig, was mir passiert ist im Supermarkt. Da gibt es ja diese Abstandshalter und dann hat die Frau vor mir Sachen aufs Band gelegt. Und dann, was ich eh schon hasse, wenn Leute dann nicht mit ihren Waren mitgehen, sondern stehen bleiben und die Waren fahren vor. Aber es geht halt ... Ist mir auch passiert. Ja, aber das Problem ist nur, weil diese Bänder sind ja dafür aus, dass man dicht aneinander steht. Nicht dicht. Doch, diese Bänder sind dafür da, eigentlich, dass man dicht aneinander steht. Ja. Und dann stand ich aber ganz weit hinten, weil ich Abstand halten habe, ich habe ein bisschen mehr Abstand gehalten als nötig, weil der kann sich ja auch bewegen plötzlich rückhaltig, deswegen habe ich noch mehr Abstand. Und dann habe ich ganz viel draufgelegt und dann sind meine Waren ganz, ganz doll weggefahren, ganz weit weggefahren und dann kam ich gar nicht hinterher und da waren riesige Lücken, teilweise lag eine Banane und dann war ich schon da und dann kam ich erst hinterher und es ist ganz plötzlich ganz so weird geworden. Ja, es ist Chaos. Und vor allem, wenn die Leute nicht mitgehen mit ihren Waren, kannst du ja nicht wie normalerweise mit einem genervten so den langen Arm machen und Sachen schon so vorlegen, wo du darfst nicht nah ran. Und dann bin ich aber trotzdem noch einen Schritt nach vorne gegangen, habe meine Sachen draufgelegt und die Frau dreht sich um und gibt mir wirklich den Blick des Todes. Wirklich so ein Du-tötest-mich-gerade-Blick, weil ich halt einen Schritt näher gegangen bin. Wirklich so diesen Blick des Todes. Wirklich so ein Du tötest mich gerade Blick,
weil ich halt einen Schritt näher gegangen bin.
Wirklich so diesen Blick des
rein Tod. Ich habe noch nie den rein Tod
in Augenform gesehen, aber das
war es einfach.
Du hast sie auch umgebracht wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe sie wahrscheinlich umgebracht, klar.
Erwidert man den Blick, hält ihm kurz stand,
aber dann ist so ein,
ich habe dann so zugenickt, weil das ist oft im Film wird es nicht gezeigt, wie man sowas auflöst. Also normalerweise Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, ist so ein, ich habe dann so zugenickt, weil das ist oft im Film wird es nicht gezeigt, wie man sowas auflöst. Also normalerweise schiesst dann jemand oder es wird selten gezeigt, wie man so diesen Blick hat und dann wieder normal weitermacht. Das sieht man selten und dann wieder aufgelöst und dann zahlt sie und ihr fällt eine Münze runter und die fällt genau auf halbem Abstand zwischen ihr und mir. Und wir beide schauen uns an und sehen diese Münze unter uns und niemand weiß, was jetzt passiert. Es war wirklich so ein Moment, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, dass der gesamte Supermarkt kurz die Luft anhält und wirklich diese Balken kommen, die Balken von oben und unten unten und ich nicht wusste, was ich tun soll und ich habe dann aber so, oh nett, ich helfe ihnen die Münze genommen und vor sich hingelegt und dann konnte sie nicht mehr böse auf mich sein und dann war sie selber so ein bisschen gefangen in einem, ich hasse ihn, aber er hat mir geholfen ich liebe ihn, ich hasse ihn aber ich hasse ihn auch, aber ich liebe ihn auch. Und es war so ein ganz klein. Aber das sind diese wenigen Momente, wo der Hass so rum noch in der Luft steht. Ja, wo man den Hass nicht loslassen will. Es ist manchmal schwer, Hass loszulassen, obwohl es an der Zeit wäre. Wo man einfach sagt, nee, Emotionen sind ja eine Investition. Emotion ist Investition, sage ich oft. Wenn du dich freust, musst du dann mit der Freude mitgehen. Du kannst dann nicht sofort wieder umschwenken. Wenn du mal gesagt hast, der Film ist so geil, und dann sagt der, hä, aber der Plot hat doch gar keinen Sinn gemacht. Dann würde ich oft gerne sagen, ja stimmt, der ist doch scheiße, der ist einfach so gut, der hat völlig recht. Ja, man sagt oft Dinge, hinter denen man gar nicht steht. Man muss auch manchmal seine Meinung wieder updaten. Ich erwische mich oft dabei, wie ich Dinge sage, die ich, also es wird nicht 50% der Fälle der Fall, dass ich einfach nicht mehr das sage, was ich denke. Man ist nur so festgefahren, also eigentlich muss man immer mal einmal die Frage stellen, ist das wirklich deine Meinung?
Bei den hitzigsten Diskussionen, die ich habe, denke ich mir wirklich in 50 Prozent der Fälle denke ich mir, nee, das ist nicht deine Meinung. Das ist einfach nur gelernt, gerade dafür zu sprechen, wenn man das mal gedacht hat kurz oder so. Ich denke mir auch immer so, ja, das ist nicht deine Meinung, aber auf der anderen Seite hast du ja auch keine Ahnung. Also vielleicht ist es fast klüger, nicht mit seiner eigenen Meinung zu sein, sich nicht selber zuzustimmen, sondern eher sich selber zu widersprechen. Weil ich denke, ich habe ja keine Ahnung von dem Thema. Vielleicht ist es klüger, jetzt einfach direkt den nächsten Schritt zu gehen und nicht meiner Meinung zu sein. Vielleicht ist das ja klarer. Ja, aber nur weil du nicht, nee, nee, nur weil du nicht, das macht auch nur in ein paar Fällen Sinn, weil, deswegen ist meine Theorie einfach den Leuten die Meinung angleichen von Leuten, die du magst auf diesem Thema. Ja, ja, so, die du attraktiv findest. Genau meine Meinung. Wenn Scott Johansson das sagt, ja, ist ja auch meine Meinung. Ist ja meine Meinung. Im Bereich Schauspiel. Ja, nee, da hat sie absolute Autorität. Im Bereich Virologie, Astrophysik, Stephen Hawking, Anna Frebel. Anna Frebel, genau. Den müssen wir auch mal wieder einladen, oder? Sehr gern. Einfach jetzt mal wirklich so eine Zwei-Stunden-Folge, einfach nur, was ist los mit Neptun? Ja. Die ganze Welt redet drüber, jetzt erklären sie es doch mal. Was ist denn da los? Wenn jetzt alle Mediziner vor die Kamera gezogen werden, würde ich jetzt gerne mal den Leuten, die jetzt gerade nicht zu Wort kommen. Ja, jetzt gerade niemand interessiert sich einen Scheiß für ihre Sternchen, die sie da vermitteln. Sie kennen ja gerade krasse Sachen, wir sind kurz vor einer krassen Supernova, Beta Goitze. Oh, ja, ist kurz davor zu explodieren, niemand weiss wann. Moment, heisst kurz davor in zehntausend Jahren? Nee, vor Millionen Jahren. In einem Zeitparadok. Nein, nein, nein, es wird in zehntausend Jahren, vor tausend Jahren explodiert worden sein. Es ist nämlich jetzt schon, also bis sie sichtbar wird jedenfalls, und dann haben wir so eine Art zweiten Mond am Himmel, weil das so nah ist, dieser Stern, und das eine Supernova wird, weil er explodiert, er hat gerade an Leuchtkraft verloren, was ein Zeichen dafür ist, dass er langsam stirbt. Und dann löst sich eine Supernova auf. Wie zweiter Mond, für wie lange? Für wie lange gibt es einen zweiten Mond? Mehrere, gut und gerne ein paar Jahre. Echt? Wir haben zwei Monde für eine, was? So eine Art. Wie? Der ist genau so hell. Fast so hell wie ein Mond. Das ist nicht dein Ernst. Wir haben bald Doppelmond? Riesensupernova. Ich habe den Artikel, der war auch dann die Hälfte weiter der Paywall und so und ob es jetzt Doppelmond war. Ja, aber ist das nicht total, aber ist das dann ein Nachtmond oder ein Tagmond? Nee, der ist ja immer dann angeknüpft. Immer an? Hey, die Supernova, die hört ja nicht auf, nur weil Tag ist hier. Die ist ja am Himmel dann, aber das ist ja egal. Der Mond ist ja auch am Tag zu sehen. Ja, aber nur so heim. Nee, der ist zu sehen und man nimmt jetzt halt holy shit. Was will er jetzt? Nee, nee, hau ab, Mond! Was will er? Hau ab, das ist jetzt nicht deine Zeit! Nein, weg! Hau ab! Das ist wie wenn du so einen Osterhasen irgendwie im Dezember siehst. Ja, in so einem Weihnachtsspot. Hau ab jetzt! Hau ab jetzt! Ich hab dich super gern, wenn deine Zeit gekommen ist. Ja, weg! Alles in Maßen! Ja! Weg! Weg! Lass jetzt mal den Weihnachtsmann machen! Jetzt ist die Sonne da! Wie oft kommt die Sonne in der Nacht raus und sagt, ich bleibe ein bisschen länger, aber hallo, ich bin auch da! Sonne, Sonne, Sonne! Nein, hau ab! Weg, Mond! Scheiss, Mond, hau ab! Bald ist Supernova, Tag und Nacht ballert die uns mit Neutronen umgeheben. Aber das ist doch schon strange, oder? Ja, ich muss mal kurz nachgucken.
Können wir kurz Frebel anrufen? Können wir das Thema kurz Frebel? Nee, ne? Die ist beschäftigt. Nova 2020. Die schaut gerade in die Sterne. Die ist gerade wo ganz anders, in anderen Milchstrassen ist sie gerade unterwegs. Ganz wochenlang Peter Goiz soll so hell leuchten wie der Vollmond. Selbst am Tageshimmel wäre das zu sehen. Kurz gesagt, es würde mächtig rumsen, sagt auch Peter Schilling. Das ist doch nicht so ein fucking Ernst. Sagt auch Peter Schilling. Hat Peter Schilling wirklich gesagt, es würde mächtig rumsen. Das ist doch knallen oder so. Hätte ich auch, ich hätte auch Doppel-M. Rumsen? Naja. Aber jetzt im Ernst, es gibt ein zweites, aber ist es dann, Moment mal dann moment mal es ist dann nicht so für so nachtaktive tiere und so ist es nicht total das problem ja ja die die die geblendet die einbrecher einbrecher haben es echt nicht leicht zum bis vor allem zombies vampir vom pire riesenproblem das ist ehemann problem dass vampire ja das franchise an im mondschein dasanchise an. Ich weiß nicht, in welchem wir leben, aber bei, also Spoiler Alert, aber der neuen Dracula-Serie wäre es kein Problem so richtig. Sonne ist kein Problem, oder was? Ja, The Walking Dead auch kein Problem. Es gibt nachtaktive Zombies, taktive Zombies. Aber Werwolf ist das, wie ist es mit Werwölfen, sind die dann dauerhaft oder was? Weil die transformieren sich ja beim Mond. Wie sind da die Regeln? Sind die gerade hart auf Mond getrimmt oder ist auch, äh, nee, ich glaube, bei Werwölfen ist schon ein Knall auf Mond. Werwolf ist Mond. Ja, ja. War ja auch Wölfe anscheinend den Mond an. Aber gibt es auch Super-Novertiere, die dann darauf... Ja, das wird sich jetzt entzeigen dann halt. Da hast du so einen Werpinguin oder so, das ist halt komplett neue, neue Gefahr. Und super ungruselig. Ja, super niedrig. Das war auch sehr lustig, wo dann die ganzen Zootiere freigelassen wurden in den Zoos. Oh ja, das war schön. Und die Pinguine, aber die einzigen waren, die sich interessiert haben, auch nur annähernd, aber die dann dafür sehr doll interessiert haben für die anderen Tiere. Die Pinguine sind als einzige wie Besucher herumgelaufen, haben die Wege benutzt, haben sich Gehege anguckt, sind stehen geblieben an den Imbissbuden, haben sich ein Eis gekauft, Klo gegangen und gross auch Drama beim Babypinguin
wie im echten, aber
die sind auch stehen geblieben vor den Gehegen, haben geguckt
und sind dann immer weitergegangen. Ah, die sind gut.
Die waren gut, aber alle anderen Tiere waren so scheiß,
denen war das scheißegal, offensichtlich.
Das hat das Video nämlich nicht gezeigt. Das Video war nur
mit so einer lustigen Musik,
halt, oh, guck mal, wie süße Pinguine sind,
aber was es nicht gezeigt hat, war, dass
alle anderen Tiere einfach grössten arroganten Arschlöcher waren wahrscheinlich, die nur in dem Gehege geblieben sind. Oder hat man nur die Pinguine freigelassen? Wie nehmen Tiere andere Tiere wahr? Ist das so auf Augenhöhe oder ist das so genauso fremd? Oder sind wir die einzigen Andersartigen? Ja, und die gehören alles zusammen, ja. Ja, wir sind alles Tiere, wie bei Madagaskar.
Ist es wie bei Madagaskar?
Naja, weil, also
wenn wir jetzt so einen Otter sehen,
denken wir uns, kein Plan,
was in dem Kopf vorgeht,
verstehe kein Wort, was der sagt,
wedelt er mit
armen Schwanz,
sagt mir nichts, kommt nichts an.
Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie so ein Huhn so einen Otter sieht, ist es dann eher so ein, er hat einen harten Dialekt, aber ich krieg's, ich versteh grob, was er meint. Oder ist da auch eine völlige Verständnis für sich? Verstehen Möpse Schäferhunde? Ja, ja, ja, ja. Und dann, nächste Frage, verstehen Füchse Schäferhunde? Ja. Verstehen Wölfe Schäferhunde? Füchse. Verstehen Füchse Katzen? Man müsste eigentlich mal so eine stille Post machen, wo man irgendwas sagt und dann geht es so durch Tiere durch und man guckt, bei welchem Tier ist es komplett verloren gegangen. Und dann vom Affen dann zu uns. Ja, genau. Die Gorillas sind den letzten und die flüstern uns so ein Bum ins Ohr.
Und man rekonstruiert, wo es komplett verloren gegangen ist dann irgendwie so.
Natürlich.
Ja, so Zahnrad.
Natürlich mit der Fledermaus.
Schlagsahne, Smabelbert.
Wie geil das wäre, wenn es in Ultraschall anfangen würde.
Ah ja, ja, ja.
Also mit Pinguinen und jetzt nicht Fledermäuse. Fledermäuse? Ne, wir lassen uns keine Fledermäuse in unser Studio. Die verdammten Fledermäuse, ne? Ja, die waren's. Batman. Covid-19? Am Ende ist es Batman. Der hieß auch Bat. Also als er noch ein Virus, extrem viele Fledermäuse war, hieß er vorher Bat. Bat-Corona. Aber ist nicht jede, ach so, ich dachte, die Fledermaus hatte den Namen Bat, was ein extremer Zufall war.
Von allen Namen, die Fledermaus haben können, hieß er Bat. Bat is my name. What's your name? Human?
Human. Human, human. Kann man sein Kind Human nennen? Mensch? Einfach nur Mensch.
Mensch Markus hieß er doch auch. Ist Mensch ein männlicher oder weiblicher Vorname? So wie Schorsch, Mensch? Nee, wie Kim. Beides? Beides, gut. Luca, Mensch. Luca? Luca gibt es auch? Frauen? Frauenmann, ja. Wie gesagt, ich kannte ein Mädchen, das hieß Luca. Aber als Abkürzung für Lucasienne. Lucanine? Nee, einfach nur straight ins Gesicht. Cool, schön. Stefan, es gibt viele wilde Dinge auf dieser Welt, nicht nur am Sternenhimmel, sondern auch auf anderen Kontinenten dieses Erdenrondes. Ich kenne vier Kontinente. Europa, Asien, Amerika und Australien. Na, da hast du aber einen ganz, ganz wichtigen vergessen. Und Antarktis. Südamerika. Südamerika. Und Afrika. Uzea. Achso. Afrika unser Lieblingskontinent, über den wir viel, viel zu wenig wissen, denn er hat viel, viel, viel zu bieten.
Und dafür sorgen wir jetzt in unserer fantast Länder Afrikas vorstellt. Denn Afrika ist kein Land, sondern ein Kontinent mit 55 Ländern drin. Stell dir das wie so ein grosses Netz Murmeln vor und das Netz zusammen ist Afrika, aber jede Murmel ist nochmal für sich ein Land und die sind teilweise ganz unterschiedlich. Ich habe es vorher besser verstanden, um ehrlich zu sein, ohne dieses Murmelbeispiel. Die sind sehr unterschiedlich und die heißen aber auch sehr gleich die Murmel, ne? Das denkt, das könnte man denken. Der gemeine Europäer. Das könnte man denken, aber das ist falsch, denn es gibt auch andere, andersnamige Länder in Afrika. Und unser heutiger Beitrag kommt von Eze Wendtoin, und der macht auch Musik. Der hat eine eigene Facebook-Seite, wo er Musik macht, da könnt ihr gerne mal vorbeigucken, haben wir alles verlinkt bei uns auf der Seite.
Er wird uns ein kleines Musikstück vortragen und uns dann ein bisschen was über sein Herkunftsland erzählen.
Und ganz, ganz viel Spaß mit der Musik von Ize.
Viel Spaß! Anusundu ye, lusundu ya, lankataye, anusundu ye, lusundu ya, lankataye, ye, for abda raga, lankataye, ye, for abda webo, lankataye, ye, for abda tuma, lankataye, ye, lankataye,, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na,prache. Ihr könnt schon mal raten, woher diese Sprache kommt. Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, deswegen möchte ich euch nicht lange weiter quälen. Diese Sprache kommt aus Burkina Faso. Burkina Faso ist ein Land aus Westafrika, die Hauptstadt von diesem Land heisst Ouagadougou. Genau, also Wakadugu. Und das Lied, das ich gerade gesungen habe, ist in meiner Muttersprache und meine Muttersprache heisst Mori, Mori, also Mori ist eine der vielen Lokalsprachen, die in Wakadugu, also in Westafrika, gesprochen wird. Burkina Faso bedeutet Land der aufrichtigen Menschen oder Land der Aufrechten. Dieser Name wurde 1983 von einem revolutionären Präsidenten eingeführt, der Präsident heisst Thomas Sankara. Thomas Sankara ist ein Präsident, den wir in Burkina Faso von 1983 bis 1987 gehabt haben. Und als er an die Macht kam, hieß das Land Obervolta, also La Houtvolta, und dieser Name ist natürlich von den Kolonialherren, also von Frankreich, eingegeben worden. Und als Thomas Sankara an die Macht gekommen ist, hat er gesagt, wir sind seit 1960 als Land unabhängig von Frankreich, warum tragen wir noch den alten Namen Oberwolter? Und dann hat er gesagt, Burkina Faso ist jetzt der neue Name und Burkina Faso besteht aus zwei Sprachen, aus zwei Lokalsprachen. Burkina ist Mori, einer der grössten Lokalsprachen, und Faso ist die zweitgrösste Lokalsprache im Land. Und mit dieser Mischung wollte er zeigen, dass Burkina-Ferso eine grosse Vielfalt an Menschen, Stämmen, an Kulturen, an Sprachen, an Lebensweisen hat. Daher ist es wichtig, dass diese Vielfalt auch im Namen des Landes widerspiegelt wird. Am Ende der Folge ist ein bisschen zu viel gewesen, um es jetzt alles hier zu zeigen. Also bleibt dran und hört noch mehr über das tolle Land Burkina Faso. Damit haben wir Burkina Faso eingeköchert in unserer kleinen Schale. Wir kriegen immer mehr, es wird langsam. Wir haben, glaube ich, jetzt fünf oder so sechs von 55, also das wird uns noch eine Weile begleiten. Aber wir bereuen es nicht, diese Rubrik angefangen zu haben, denn es ist ein Kontinent, der sich lohnt. Und ich habe auf Twitter einige Nachrichten bekommen,
denn es passiert manchmal, dass
bei Wer wird
Millionär zum Beispiel eine Frage gestellt
wird, über die wir auch schon mal im Podcast
geredet haben, und dann schicken uns immer ganz
viele Hörer die Folge so,
ah, wegen Podcast-Ufo wusste ich das, was einerseits
zeigt, wie unfassbar krasse
Quoten Wer wird Millionär immer noch hat, dass mindestens fünf Leute uns das schicken, also rein anteilmäßig musste das ja enorm viele Leute gucken, und freut uns natürlich immer wieder, dieses Mal ging es darum, wovon wird Westafrika gerade geplagt, und richtig war Heuschreckenplage. Aber, ja, gut, freut uns auf jeden Fall, dass ihr da immer mehr was dazu lernen könnt und jetzt auch über Burkina-Fase. Aber der spannende Part von Afrika ist ja der jetzt folgende. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia. Ich lerne die Länder Afrikas und ich merke mir Namibia und Uganda. Ich merke mir Namibia, Uganda, Tansania. Ich merke mir Namibia, Uganda, Tansania und Äthiopien. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Ruanda. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Sambia, Ruanda. Erst Sambia. Sambia? Glaube ich. Sambia, Ruanda. Stimmt. Also, okay, jetzt alle. Namibia, Uganda, Tansania, Äthiopien, Sambia, Ruanda, Burkina Faso. Das ist nie halten wir das durch. Wir haben nie im Leben. Und es klingt aber immer noch auch sehr viel gleich. Aber kleiner Tipp für alle Stadtland-Fluss-Freunde da draußen, ihr werdet eine Menge mitnehmen aus dieser Rubrik und ihr werdet die Leute an die Wand Stadtland-Fluss. Und ihr merkt, erkennt Podcast-Hörer dann daran, weil die auf der Kategorie Land bestehen, als einzige, weil sonst immer so, nee, lass mal lieber Musiker nehmen oder Wortwaffe.
Machen wir Land oder machen wir afrikanisches Land? Können wir auch machen, ja.
B, Belgien, Belgien, Belgien, Burkina Faso, zack die zehn Punkte.
Muttersprache in Afrika, finde ich auch ganz gut.
Das war Antenafrika.
Und das war auch schon diese Folge für diese Woche.
Wir wünschen euch weiterhin viel Spaß beim Drinbleiben und allem, was ihr drin tut.
Stay healthy, kauft nicht so viel, kauft die Dinge, die überbleiben. Das mache ich jetzt immer. Ich kaufe das, was am meisten noch da ist. Ich habe die grässlichsten Seifen bei mir jetzt zu Hause stehen. Herzlichste Skopafil. Ja, vor allem, es sind ja nicht alle Nudeln ausverkauft, sondern nur die guten Nudeln.
Und was übrig bleibt, sind zum Beispiel diese ganz dünnen Spaghetti.
Die niemand will.
Die niemand will. Die niemand will. Und am Ende... Hat mich perfekt, mal jetzt zu sehen, was in die Leute einen Scheiß. Ja. Zum Beispiel, das ganze Seifenregal war leer. Ausser eine Seife, die war noch komplett da. Und dann denke ich mir, warum? Weil dann kann man die, dann dreht man die um und dann habe ich gesucht, fehlt da irgendwie Alkohol, also fehlt da das, was die Viren zerstört. Keine Ahnung. Naja. Nein, das ist auch Seife. Es ist schwer aus dem Stehgreif zu bewerten im Supermarkt. Musste ich auch nicht. Aber alle Leute haben gezielt sich alle gegen diese eine Seife, die noch da war. Es war sogar Palmoliv, kann ich noch sagen, Palmoliv? Oh. Nee, so heißt die Marke. Oh, aber das hätte ich nicht genommen. Es das einzige, was noch da war? Nee. Palmolive? Hätte ich nicht genommen. Warum nicht? Die ist furchtbar. Das weiß aber jeder, dass die wirklich, das ist die schrecklichste Seife der Welt. Woher wissen Sie das? Die ist furchtbar. Das heißt, da weiß wirklich jeder, Stefan, niemals diese Seife kaufen. Und dann bin ich nach Hause und habe herausgefunden, warum. Sie ist Schaum. Die ist nur Schaum? Sie ist Schaumseife. Das ist doch ganz geil. Ganz geil. Das ist die Einschaum. Ja. Ich esse jetzt so ganz dünne Spaghetti, wie so ein wildes Tier. Ja, du mit der Dünnst Spaghetti ist nicht mit einer Schaumseife. Schaumparty und Spaghetti. Dünne Spaghetti. Ich fühle mich manchmal, als wäre ich riesengroß, weil die Spaghetti so ganz dünn sind. Und ich stelle mir vor, dass ich so ein Riese bin, der diese ganz kleinen Spaghetti aufnimmt. Es macht Spaß, wir wünschen euch weiterhin viel Erfolg dabei. Und alles Gute, wir sehen uns nächste Woche wieder. Wir sehen uns nächste Woche. Bis dann, ciao. Ciao, ciao. Das heisst, dass es in Burkina Faso mehr als 60 Menschengruppen, Menschenstämme gibt. Und dadurch gibt es natürlich auch mehr Sprachen, viele Sprachen, viele Religionen, viele Kulturen. Aber ich muss sagen, dass Burkina Faso ein vorbildliches Land ist, weil das Land gilt bis zu den letzten zwei, drei Jahren als friedliches Land, die Menschen leben friedlich zusammen, trotz ihrer unterschiedlichen Religionen, ihrer unterschiedlichen Kulturen, Sprachen usw. Ja, nur bis zu den letzten zwei, drei Jahren gibt es vor allem im Norden von dem Lande Terrorattacken, und das stuft das Land ein bisschen als unfriedliches Land, würde ich sagen. Aber ich glaube, bisher leben die Menschen immer noch friedlich miteinander und bestimmte Werte werden im Vordergrund gebracht, sodass die Menschen lernen, dass diese Terrorgruppen den Krieg und das Durcheinander in dem Land sehen möchten und dass die Menschen lernen sollten, miteinander zu leben. Genau, also, und ich habe in Burkinawa so ein Schulprojekt angefangen. Wir sind fest der Meinung, dass Bildung und Kunst zwei Sagen sind, die ein Land voranbringen können, die einem Land eine gewisse Stabilität geben können. Daher habe ich 2016 in Burkina-Fasso einen Verein gegründet, zusammen mit anderen kulturschaffenden Menschen, Frauen, Freunden, Lehrerinnen usw. Und ja, das Ziel ist es, eine Schule zu bauen, und in dieser Schule werden Kinder aufgenommen werden, die die Möglichkeit haben, Lesen und Schreiben zu erlernen. Und wir möchten vor allem Wert auf junge Frauen legen, weil wir denken, dass die Frauen mehr benachteiligt sind, und das Ziel ist, in diesem Schulzentrum, das aus einer Schule und einem Fraueninternat bestehen wird, also junge Frauen aufzunehmen, die die Möglichkeit haben, einen Handwerksberuf zu erlernen. Wir denken, dadurch werden die Frauen unabhängiger von ihren Männern, viele sind immer noch unter Druck, sozusagen, und ja, wir denken, dass mit Bildung und die Möglichkeit, künstliche Aktivitäten zu machen oder handwerkliche Tätigkeiten zu erlernen, diese Menschen die Möglichkeit haben können, unabhängig und selbstständig zu werden. Daher gibt es jetzt das Schulprojekt Wakansiel in Burkina Faso,
also vor allem in Wakadugu, in der Nähe von Wakadugu. Es ist etwa 30 Kilometer entfernt von Wakadugu,
wo das Schulprojekt stattfinden soll. Ich war zum Beispiel vor zwei Jahren da mit meinem Kumpel Christian, und da wurde dokumentiert, wie wir einen Brunnen auf dem Grundstück gebaut haben für die Menschen vor Ort, damit sie Zugang zu sauberem Wasser haben können. Ja, das ist ein kleines Land, sehr bekannt, würde ich sagen, durch die Revolution über Thomas Sankara, der aber 1987 von seinem besten Kumpel Blaise Compaoré ermordet wurde, mit der Hilfe, ich würde sagen, von Frankreich und der Elfenbeinküste, weil Thomas Ankara ein Präsident gewesen ist, der sich gegen Postkolonialismus, gegen Imperialismus, gegen Ausbeutung klar positioniert hat und er stand natürlich den Franzosen im Weg und deswegen hatte er ein kurzes Regier in Burkina Faso. Burkina Faso ist ein witziges, kleines Land mit sehr vielen Menschen, die ganz stolz sind. Es gibt sehr viel Kultur auf der Strasse, die Kinder sind aufgeweckt, die Kunst ist auf der Strasse zu finden.
Es gilt als armes Land, man muss immer fragen, was arm bedeutet, ich glaube, es geht den Menschen super gut, weil sie miteinander leben, weil sie füreinander stehen, weil sie teilen, zum Beispiel bei Festen, Weihnachten, teilen die Christenessen mit den Muslimen, die nicht feiern. Und ja, genauso geht es auch den Muslimen, wenn sie Zuckerfest feiern, die kochen mehr und teilen mit den anderen, die kein Zuckerfest feiern. Das ist immer gemeinsam und das ist ein grosser Wert, den Burkina Faso hat. Deswegen lade ich euch alle ein, nach Burkina Faso zu fliegen. Wenn man googelt, wird man Schreck bekommen, weil die Medien alles hochhocken. Das gilt als ein Land, das man gerade nicht erreichen sollte oder wohin man nicht gehen sollte. Aber ja, ich bin ab und zu wieder in Burkina Faso, weil es da ganz gut gefällt. Ich habe da meine Freunde, meine Familie. Ich kann da vor allem wieder auftanken, aus dem deutschen Stress wegzugehen, wegzudenken und wieder auf dem Boden zu landen und im Staub mein Glück zu finden. Von daher lade ich euch gerne ein wenn ihr bock habt kommt mit nach burkina faso ihr könnt auch in unserem schulprojekt mitwirken wir legen los ab nächstem jahr und ja natürlich können sie auch für das schulprojekt spenden wenn googeln, finden Sie Informationen über Schulprojekt
wakaciel, w a r c minus e n minus c i e l. Genau. Ja, das war eine kleine Stadtrundfahrt in Burkina Faso, vor allem in Wakadugu, wo ich gebogen bin.
Vielen Dank und auf Wiederhören. Ciao.